okay the Patriots are in the Super Bowl
this weekend and the eggman called in on
our voicemail number two one nine to
david p he is i guess against the
Patriots as many people are but he made
an argument that I had not heard before
take a listen to this one it is the
Patriots are just white privilege in a
uniform they definitely will win they
definitely will be eating KFC and Burger
King at the White House after and they
definitely will cheat to get there I I
don't know even what this means the
Patriots are white privilege I mean Tom
Brady is white and Bill Belichick is
white but do you I mean Pat I guess
maybe I just don't know are the is there
a particular deficit of non-white
players on the Patriots I don't think so
but certainly the most prominent players
on the Patriots are white Tom Brady Rob
Gronkowski Julian Edelman so maybe
that's what he's going with here
alright maybe the egg vans right I mean
geez I don't know they don't seem to
know enough about football but I will I
am separating politics from sports when
it comes to the Super Bowl I don't know
if Tom Brady actually likes Trump I know
he was spotted with the mag AHA but his
wife Giselle said no no no this is not
our supporting Donald Trump as president
of the United States I don't know I want
to see a good game won by the Patriots
and we will see how it actually turns
out and will I'm sure be discussing it
on Monday we've got a great bonus show
for you today get the bonus show by
being a member or a patron that's the
show